oh let me get in the position oh it's
like a fanfiction mama me I am NOT going
we go at the up at the here
can we go Bowser you can go fight Bowser
[ __ ] at the bottom it's camera Mario I
drop my waiting thing what he see you
hit wait you've met you're married yes
who do way who'd you marry the Bowser
you married Bowser you talking this so
nice it did to me I don't know why you
don't get the Lord I love him dude they
had some trippy enemies in in these
games like what the [ __ ] is a lip you oh
really
flip kneeble flip me hey you racist son
of a swine I don't want you he's like
well flip at the Mario flip me if you
would go in the same time Jesus Christ
come here but he turns towards me oh
he's coming towards me I would a [ __ ]
you'll get on it get on it pushing me
bandit push me son of a [ __ ]
oh my god in secret we'll see you could
its brother what's in here nothing ah
I'm sorry about your marriage you know
it's just not fair
can't see but I love at the him at least
he loved with me not like your picture
the B it should use under the beach you
[ __ ] Italian brothers huh you must
see the nasty with the best how do I do
the backflips again [ __ ] this Oh
get rekt you [ __ ]
don't leave me hey leave her you forever
Oh No
no you need to get up there with it Oh
with the guy he's gay
I beat it too many GG at the top start
at the bottom now I'm here I am typing
balls on Luigi I'm so scared at the wall
real likes it when you do that
I hear oh I was not to do in an ass
thing like mirrors [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] the meat beer oh the wall
ate me Luigi snowman's yes highest this
is the map I wanna play this out what is
nice yeah [ __ ] that puzzle it's annoying
as [ __ ] did you say [ __ ] you [ __ ]
with us
stop hitting that button shut up I love
the pizza what is happening look at my
butt you go oh you wiggle it bigger on
the outfall you think at the balusters
we like into this why we do this it's a
family thing we can work it so well
yeah [ __ ] jump on you okay so we got
sacrifice the ping with the save me yes
we go way to sacrifices penguin in the
name of fashion we got to make some
penguin skin boots if the path that
penguin we must make them into a pair of
boots if we don't make this penguin into
a boot we'd have to adopt him come on
Luigi you're gonna die wait clone itself
oh I'm going the right way I don't know
Oh God oh yeah I am penguin good job
good job
idiot [ __ ] it's a creature do we thing
is no Matt no no you hear him god oh god
oh my god you scrub but I died I will be
the boots now oh my god idiot I think
you just like jump off on the edge here
and make it all way the bottom half
you [ __ ] at the crazy yeah you're right
I paid it
alright well watch me do it are you
[ __ ] kidding me right now with this
goddamn penguin
Jeff off are you gonna go so far around
oh god oh god oh god
a little song of travel all right you go
first and show me how it's done
just like you've slot off and just hold
lift you just wow right here okay
hold down tough man okay go back go back
go back many times to present to you the
pad at the boot what I will not accept
any offer in less than 50 euro 50 euro
this guy is the cheapest I will snow how
do i how do I kill him right that's what
happens if you [ __ ] that we lead
Italians booze honks I was so scared at
this when I was a kid this is so [ __ ]
scary Luigi I don't know what I want I
don't know if I want to be here and I've
never been scaring him like this before
all right we're uh we're supernatural
I'm Dean and you're Sam Sam you can't
just go around being friends with demon
Sam bit dear niece Sam they're not nice
they'll go to Petraeus think Oh think of
Bobby but my girlfriend eh I don't like
no Sam Dean I'm daddy I did wait
whatsapp sound drunk I'm fine a bum let
me give you back massage thank you for
saving me Sam
Dina you've been working so hard lately
yeah well you know it's uh it's do my
job
whoa that's a merry-go-round oh my god
I lost no you wouldn't not believe my
beliefs some so motion sick right now
I'll ask it of my waiting
life you know watching and every liking
you get our pizza from Maya's mama